all right i am going to record again uh
for starters i think i'm on like a
30-day streak of videos right now don't
get used to it because i'm going to
start work at some point but
it's probably longer than i've ever even
streaked a girl on snapchat because i
don't talk to girls because i am a
software engineer so
anyways that being said i'm pretty burnt
out but uh let's keep making videos
because i am validation hungry and i
have a fragile ego
it's park it time baby here we go
okay park it well basically in the past
or actually last video i discussed abro
thrift and protocol buffers which are
all ways of serializing data in a
row-based format so that's really useful
for any type of time where you're going
to be up uploading or you know
retrieving a couple of rows of data at a
time right you want the entire row
however as i've mentioned in the past a
very common use case in a lot of big
companies is to basically be doing
analytics processing and when you do
that you want to be retrieving data that
is basically from some set of columns in
a huge gigantic hadoop table or sql
table or something along those lines and
as a result it's very important to kind
of have data locality in those columns
and so what parkit basically is is
another library that actually goes and
helps manage that
you know storing of data and columns in
a way that not only allows for more
efficient querying of data within those
columns but in addition to that reduces
the i o of sending all of that data over
the network by using some pretty cool
compression techniques so let's go ahead
and talk about that
okay so parkit even though i mentioned
column oriented storage thus far is
really more of a hybrid oriented storage
so let me discuss what that means well
we've spoken about
oriented and storage in the past which
is basically just saying
all the entries in a single row of data
are stored together and the issue with
that is for analytics processing where
we really only care about you know the
values of one column over all the rows
that's pretty useless to us because we
don't get data locality
we have column oriented storage which is
basically where you're taking all of the
rows in the table and storing the values
of you know the same column next to one
another so that's really nice for
analytics processing but it comes with
the cost of if you're ever trying to do
random accesses or maybe just trying to
go ahead and put one row back together
all of those values from
you know the same row are going to be
super far from one another on the disk
and as a result having to do all those
seeks is going to take a really long
time so instead we have this third
approach called the hybrid model where
basically that involves going ahead and
taking a table and splitting it first of
all real wise into you know a bunch of
different partitions and then on each
partition using column oriented storage
so looking at the image below imagine
that we split between row two and row
three and then within that we're using
column oriented storage so a0 a1 and a2
since they're in the same column are
stored together b0 b1 and b2 same deal
c0 c1 c2 also stored together and then
we start that partition and do the same
exact thing for the latter three rows
okay so what is um park it how do we
store the data why is it useful
basically here we go data is going to be
split into these parkit files which
contain multiple row groups where row
groups are basically those partitions
that i just mentioned prior
of those rows so you know it might be
three rows it might be you know 100 rows
probably it's going to be a pretty big
amount of them because i think the
default value for a row group is 128
megabytes worth of row data which is
actually quite a bit but obviously if
you're looking at a table that's
gigabytes or terabytes in size that
gives you a lot of room to have a bunch
of partitions
additionally each one of these parkit
files is going to have a footer which
contains some metadata pertaining to the
information in the row groups but
basically within each row group we
obviously have a bunch of columns that
we have to represent and then within
each of those columns columns are broken
down into chunks and even further into
one megabyte pages so the thing with
these pages is that all of these pages
are going to contain some metadata about
the encoded data so the encoded data is
going to be you know that small amount
of columnar data that's
local to one another and so things that
you might include in that
basically in that metadata section are
something like a min or a max of that
data set
a count of the number of points in there
possibly even a dictionary representing
the elements of the data and if you want
like a more space efficient
approximation of a dictionary you could
perhaps use a bloom filter and that's
something that was recently introduced
to parkit
but i'll explain in a little bit how
that's all useful
okay so let's talk about data encoding
so imagine right now we have a list of
values right and there are basically all
the values in um
one column for a set of adjacent rows
well basically the naive implementation
is to use a plane encoding where you
know if all the data is the same length
you know say it's like a time stamp or
something and every time stamp is i
don't know 20 digits you can basically
just go ahead and store the raw data
without any limitations in terms of you
know how long is the actual time stamp
itself because we know we can just run a
loop over every 20 digits and then you
know pull out our time step
that being said if the data is of
varying lengths you know maybe we're
storing strings there instead of
something like a timestamp we can go
ahead and first store an integer before
every single string basically
representing the length of it and then
store the string itself so that's how we
would go ahead and decode that plane
encoding but that being said the reality
is we can generally do a lot better than
this the cool thing about columnar data
is that generally speaking a there are a
lot of duplicates because over one
column there just probably are going to
be duplicates over all those rows and
then b is that if we have you know
duplicates that are adjacent to one
another as in we have a lot of repeated
values next to one another then we can
really start to compress it and we do
this
with dictionary compression run length
encoding and bit packing and i'll show
this off in the next slide
so imagine we have the following
columnar data that starts out on the
left there we have this uncompressed
data of a bunch of strings of countries
and what we see here that within those
strings of countries we have a ton of
duplicates such that there are really
only four unique values well the first
thing then that we would actually do is
create a dictionary that goes ahead and
gives each country a unique index in the
dictionary so now every time i see zero
i know that corresponds to the united
states one corresponds to france and so
on and so i can actually take that
uncompressed columnar data and replace
every single one of those strings with
an actual number which i know takes a
lot less space
additionally something cool that we can
do with this dictionary is instead of
using a full 64-bit number to represent
each of these numbers i can actually
represent all of these numbers using
just two bits the reason for that are
that there are only four entries in the
dictionary and as we know just based on
powers of two i can represent four
numbers using just two bits so in that
way that's called bit packing so we're
able to save even more space there then
finally what we have is run length
encoding so this is really useful when
we have not only just duplicate values
but duplicate values that are next to
each other so you can see there that in
that final compression in the bottom
right we have zero one two three comma
three one and zero and the reason that
we're able to do three comma three and
compress things further is the fact that
there are three threes that are next to
one another so basically we just go
ahead and create a tuple that says the
number of times that this number occurs
and the actual number itself so in this
case there are three consecutive threes
hence three comma three
so that this process allows us to hugely
compress all of this data which is
really nice and it gets even better if
you know we were to go ahead and
pre-sort the data in some way that would
um allow us to compress this column even
further
okay so what about just like the chunk
size because i mentioned that columns
are split into chunks and there are
advantages and disadvantages to having
big chunks and small chunks from each of
these columns in a certain row space
so the first thing is that if chunks are
too big basically
dictionary compression is going to not
work as well because we only have so
much space to store our dictionary in
and so if there are too many values in
that chunk too many unique values we
can't fit them all in the dictionary
and so it not only is it going to take
more bits to represent each entry of the
dictionary but if we can't even fit
every single value in the dictionary
then the values that can't be fit in the
dictionary are just going to have to use
plain encoding and we're just going to
have to store them as they were
originally written so we would get no
benefit there hence sometimes it's
better to actually decrease the size of
those chunks so that you can actually
use a dictionary to represent all of the
unique values of the columnar data in
that chunk
furthermore however it's not great to
use overly small chunks the reason being
that i mentioned every single chunk has
a metadata section and if we have too
many small chunks we're going to end up
storing a ton of metadata and that
incurs a lot of overhead in terms of the
amount of disk space that we use and
obviously the amount of um
basically information that we have to
send over the network if we were to run
like a batch process on this
okay so now we're actually going to talk
about the metadata because this enables
us to do something known as predicate
push down and this is actually a really
useful feature of parkit beyond just the
encoding that i've talked about in
perhaps past videos
so let's say we want to run a query over
all of the rows of a given column and so
we basically want to say find all rows
where some value x is greater than 69.
basically
we know that every single page has
metadata telling us the min and the max
of each row so if we see that you know
the min is zero and the max is 20 we
know we can skip over that entire chunk
of data and so this greatly allows us to
speed up the process and it's super
useful to kind of have this metadata
additionally in cases where
we actually pre-sorted the data like i
mentioned before this would allow us to
skip even more stuff over because then
you know our first chunk would have say
values zero to two the second chunk two
to four the third chunk three to six and
so as a sorry uh you know four to six
but the point is that we could then skip
over pretty much you know say the entire
first half of the data and only start
reading from the second half of the
chunks because our sorted data is
basically telling us there's nothing
that we're interested in in the first
half of all of this data
another cool thing that we can do is
instead of just
looking at rows where you know we want a
value greater than some threshold if
we're trying to find all rows where
some certain value is contained in that
chunk we can actually use the dictionary
that is being used to compress the chunk
to basically go ahead and tell us if a
certain value is in a chunk so you know
like from our country's example before
if i wanted to find all the rows where
you know country equals united states i
can see that united states is present in
the dictionary for that chunk and as a
result i know i can go ahead and check
that chunk and if i see the dictionary
of a different chunk where united states
is not in there then i would go ahead
and skip over that thus saving me some
processing time
you may actually think to yourself and
this is a pretty cool thing is that oh
you know if the dictionaries are taking
up too much space we don't actually want
to keep track of all those unique values
one optimization that we could do here
for set approximation without taking up
too much space would actually be to use
a bloom filter and that's something
that's recently been supported by parkit
and it is kind of an interesting
optimization to see these come into play
yet again in order to perform that set
approximation for predicate pushdown
and then furthermore you can also
partition the predicate file or the the
parkit files themselves because
the parkit files can basically have
directories and subdirectories and so
what you could do for example is say you
know you have a bunch of data
corresponding to the dates you could
basically have all the data
all the columnar data
corresponding to say like january 1st in
one packet file and then all the
columnar data corresponding to january
2nd in a different parkit file and then
that way you could further use that to
enforce predicates because if we only
wanted the january first data we could
just check that parkit file and thus
that greatly reduces the amount of
search or query time that we're actually
going to be doing
okay so in conclusion i know this is a
pretty quick video but parkit is
actually super useful in either a data
warehousing or data-like situation in
the sense that anytime you want to be
performing a bunch of batch processes
for either something like an etl job or
just analytics being able to compress
data stored in a column oriented format
as well as quickly query it using this
extra metadata for predicate push down
is super useful
parkit is extremely commonly used like i
mentioned in data lakes and you know
there's a company called databricks that
basically is is you know heavily
supporting the use of parkit within
their own data lakes and as a result
parkit is not something that is you know
inherently
a rival to avro thrift or protocol
buffers but in fact what you would do is
you would use them in conjunction with
one another where you would first
compress every single row using average
thrifter protocol buffers and then
taking that compressed row data you
could go ahead and use something like
park it to compress it in a column wise
manner and that way you're making sure
that you're incurring minimal network
latency whenever you're doing these huge
big data tasks because at the end of the
day generally speaking it's faster to
use cpu cycles to serialize and
deserialize certain data especially in a
batch processing context than it is to
basically go ahead and send a bunch of
crap over the network
okay guys i hope this one makes sense a
little mini video but i'll be back
tomorrow